quel est votre salaire dans touche pas à
mon poste quelque 6 500 700 euros par
émission voila voila merci match que
j'avais je le sais je connais même pas
les salaires de chasse du cac - comme
jean-michel semaine le magazine télé 2
semaines qui en ce moment au kiosque a
révélé lors d'une grande enquête les
salaires bruts des présentateurs
chroniqueurs et comédien à la télé on va
vous révéler les chiffres il ya une
grosse partie des enquêtes qui porte sur
les chroniqueurs de tpm paix et de
balances ton post ils disent aussi dans
lequel je vous dis le journaliste ne
révèle pas le salaire il a dit je ne
révèle pas le salaire d'arthur de nagui
ni de cyril hanouna
car difficile à établir avec avec
précision voilà donc voilà il n'y pas
voilà donc je dis voilà il est donc
valérie benaïm j'aurais dû dire sartec
ben je vais me rencontrent surtout que
benjamin est quatre fois plus payer que
moi alors mais celle d'henry king comme
ma maison me et son binôme une
fourchette très large en excuser moi et
benjamin castaldi qui n'a d'ailleurs pas
eu le courage de venir aujourd'hui
igal 4000 euros par prime c'est aucun
intérêt parce qu'il a prise à jamais
confirmé l'attendait basse et il va nous
le dire
le praticien les yeux
[Applaudissements]
j'espère en bourse et alors et on rigole
mais ce sont des sommes astronomiques 1
on va pas se mentir vous serrez voilà il
faut savoir benjamin castaldi vous savez
que quand ils pouvaient toucher pour une
saison de loft story époque il touché
600 mille euros pour la saison
oui mais lui gagne 4000 euros mais
combien de temps il travaille pas nous
on est des acteurs de ya des moments où
pendant six sept voire huit mois on
travaille pas du tout et et on gagne 10
milles sur un coup et mais il faudrait
pouvoir manger pendant des mois je veux
que vous connaissez bien moi c'est là
elle sait pas gérer la dalle ça fait
longtemps je suis pas monté sur scène où
j'ai mis de côté on m'a pris non mais
c'est pareil je n'aurais pas cru bon non
mais c'est vrai que la dernière fois que
suis monté sur scène ça fait presque
quoi un an
d'accord bah comment tout ça à côté
ouais bien sûr mais bon c'est vrai que
ces déchets après après c'est vrai que
je vois que vous connaissez mal l'équipe
de touche pas à mon poste
si vous aviez quand il travaille
travaille jamais je préfère vous le dire
moi je mal parce que voilà wallace ne
sert des autres ça m'intéresse donc ça
ne me choque pas qu'on me demande mon
salaire à moi schultz à onet battu mon
salaire ne touche pas à mon poste le 6
500 700 euros par émission
voila voila merci m as tu vu que j'avais
je le sais je connais même pas les
salaires de choc à moins que jean michel
[Rires]
phil dent sur plaisance et je sais j'y
jetterai villégier vraiment privilégié
par émission là mais oui morcellement de
ce que tu me donne je donne la moitié à
je l'attends ce que tu me dis non tu
sais il ya des gens qui appellent au
téléphone et qui se font passer pour
l'état cette attention à ça mais la
première c'est quoi je donne la moitié
de ce que je gagne chez toi à une
association qui s'occupe de pauvres par
exemple de m'a parlé d'un cas de il y
aurait des gens qui quittent téléphone
et qui se ferait passer pour la
plusieurs auraient aussi des gens qui
essaient l'association dissimule
répondre des terrains à l'étranger quand
tu arrives ya pas de bourse évoqué le
bien sûr que sur capital celui de ce que
je gagne gens voient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]